كلوا هذه المشاكل التي ذكرناها لا تاتي
فرادى وانما بالجمله على راس الملياردير
الامريكي الى الماسك الرجل المثقل بهم
متفوتري يواجهوا جبهه اخرى مشتعله ايضا
وهي تسلق السياره الحديثه الانيقه
المتطوره لكن ماذا يحدث
بس لا استدعت اليوم اكثر من 320 الف
السياره في امريكا بسبب مشكله فنيه واما
في الصين فهناك حوادث بسبب هذه الاعطال
وتحديدا برنامج القياده الذاتي وتسببت
بمقتل اشخاص الحادث الاخيره كانت ماده
دسمه لاطراف التهاجم ماسك وتسلق وتحديد
برنامج القياده الذاتيه الخاص بالشركه ضمن
بروجكت
حمله اعلاميه ضد ماسك وبرنامجيه للقياده
الذاتيه الكامله واطلقها الرئيس التنفيذي
لاكبر شركه التكنولوجيا شركات التكنولوجيا
الولايات المتحده
لكن هل تتخيلون انه انفق ملايين الدولارات
لشراء مركبات تسلم واختبار تلك
التكنولوجيا
فاستراتيجيته تعتمد على توثيق الادله ضد
البرنامج
الذاتيه يرتكب خطا ان كل تماني رقائق
وتستند في هذه في ذلك على تحليل عشرات
الساعه من لقطه مصوره وللمفارقه ان حادث
الصين وهي بالمناسبه ثاني اكبر سوق لتسلا
ياتي قبل اسابيع من هدفا اعلنه ماسك البدء
ببيعه سيارات تسلا الكهربائيه ذاتيه
القياده بشكل كامل نهايه العالم